lancé en mars 2010 est le dispositif rsa
et bénévolat d'abord envisagé comme une
obligation finalement pris la forme
d'une plateforme internet de mise en
contact entre associations et
allocataires sur la base du volontariat
un système qui a déjà été testé par 850
allocataires dont patrice et monique qui
nous livre ce soir leur expérience
reportage stéphane baudry et christian
les mails il y a passé un mois et demi à
arpenter les rues de tanner vieux thann
pour recenser les commerces les artisans
et les locaux vacants pour le compte de
l'association des enseignes du pays thur
doller un travail mais un travail que
patrice a effectué un bénévole dans le
cadre de son rsa
un principe qui ne le choque pas lui qui
était déjà bénévole au sein du club de
rugby local puis je vois maintenant levé
nivellera bénévolat parlons c'est un
esprit de de l'équipe et de partage qui
est très important à mon avis de nos
jours qu'il faut essayer de développer
au mieux quoi et au rugby et au rugby
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on fait tout
naturellement un gentillet j'ai encadré
représente une tâche réalisée avec
d'autant plus de bonne volonté que cette
mission lui a permis d'étoffer son
réseau professionnel naissant lui qui
veut lancer une entreprise de
communication n'a pas porté par
communiqué avec mais les personnes qui
ont les commerces et de constituer un
réseau puisque ça ira dans la continuer
dans la continuité parle mais ce que je
veux faire c'est à dire hors
auto-entrepreneurs une entreprise de
création audiovisuelle
autre parcours autre histoire monica
consacré sa vie à l'éducation de ses
enfants mais à la proche de la retraite
elle se retrouve seule avec des ménages
pour vivre et le rsa pour assurer les
périodes creuses
pour elle le bénévolat c'est surtout une
manière de retrouver une vie sociale
quand toit du monde tous et s'installe
agréable ça fait sortir dans la semaine
j'ai une fois par semaine jean rendez
vous ici et si elle a choisi de
consacrer une partie de son temps libre
à vélo docteur c'est parce qu'elle aime
bricoler pour elle le dispositif du
conseil départemental ne peut marcher
que s'il est pleinement consenties par
les allocataires faut choisir dans le
bénévolat des choses qu'on a envie de
faire et qui nous plaisent
mais nous la joue pas que ça soit une
corvée il faut que ça soit un plaisir et
si vous avez vu bon l'ambiance est bonne
et puis et puis moi j'aime bricoler
lancé en mars 2010 est le dispositif a
reçu près de 1400 proposition 850
allocataires ayant répondu sur les dix
sept mille que compte le haut rhin notre
dossier de ce